[Musique]
kick boxeur l'héritage
retrouvez la suite de la nouvelle saga
kick boxeur jean-claude van damme de
retour accompagné par mike tyson et
christophe lambert
kick boxeur l'héritage maintenant
disponible en blu ray dvd et vod avec
amc
mesdames et messieurs le vainqueur
quatre fois content de te revoir
il est temps pour toi de défendre son
titre lors d'un nouveau et papa maman ou
du passera le reste de ta vie en prison
je te présente non qu est un spécimen
d'humains supérieur plus grand plus fort
que n'importe quel être humain sur cette
planète
ça arrivera pas il faut qu'on trouve un
moyen de faire avancer les choses
ils ont kidnappé ta femme il faut que tu
commences à t'entraîner
l'homme le plus fort ne gagnent pas
toujours le plus intelligent 6
la force contre sa faiblesse
et sa faiblesse c'est une bonne question
et te suffira de t'asseoir
et de profiter du voyage
ta interrompu ma méditation ça t'aide à
rester calme tirez pas